quand on achète de la viande au
supermarché on ignore souvent les
conditions dans lesquelles ces animaux
là on était élevé mais il faut dire tout
de suite que ce n'est pas facile de
trouver un équilibre entre bien-être
animal et viabilité économique
aujourd'hui on se penche sur l'élevage
intensif des porcs plus particulièrement
sur celui des truies qui sont encore
majoritairement garder en cage toute
leur vie au canada
[Musique]
et
moi ce que je veux c'est donner le plus
de confort possible aux animaux voire
aucune souffrance dans la femme de
l'homme y'a pas de coupes de que ils
seront prélevés sur le béton qui ont été
levés sur de l'appareil
[Musique]
l'élevage intensif de porcs donne
souvent lieu à des manipulations qui
compromettent leur bien-être
la castration elle même la question
qu'il faut se poser c'est pourquoi on
inflige cette douleur là aux animaux est
ce que cette pratique là est justifiée
on incise le scrotum des porcelets on
tire les testicules qui on coupe où on
arrache le cordon spermatique
donc c'est une opération extrêmement
douloureuse
le grand public lui ignore généralement
comment on élève ses animaux est ce que
vous savez dans quel genre de cases les
truies sont élevées ce à dire à peine
plus grand que leur fort deux fois plus
grand que leur corps ou trois fois je
dirais trois fois parce que les petits
cochons il faut qu'ils boivent aussi
provoqué des proches mais aussi
certaines la grandeur de son corps deux
par set oh la la
donc sans vraiment la tête d'un côté les
que de l'opinion reste là exact jusqu'à
l'abattage oui
ok
[Applaudissements]
je pense que des gens probablement ne se
pose même pas la question ils achètent
barquettes de viande sur l'étal et ne se
pose pas forcément la question comment
les animaux ont été levés quand cela à
partir d'un certain point si on veut
vraiment améliorer les conditions
d'élevage des animaux il faut être prêt
à mettre le prix que ça coûte de les
élever correctement
détruis enfermées toute leur vie dans
des cages à peine plus grande que leur
corps des animaux stressés qui mordent
les barreaux
ces images ont alerté l'opinion publique
en angleterre à la fin des années 90 et
ont mené à l'abolition des cages de
gestation dans plusieurs pays européens
tout le contraire du canada ou 53%
détruit passent leur vie entière dans
des cages d'un peu plus de deux pieds
par cents
lorsqu elles allaitent elles sont
toujours confinés dans le même espace
même si une aire distinctes et réservée
aux porcelets une réalité dont les
principaux acteurs de l'industrie
porcine conventionnelles ont refusé de
nous parler
normand gagné lui a tourné le dos à
cette façon de faire en se consacrant à
l'élevage de porc biologique
bush en effet bel vache conventionnelle
je retournerais pas en arrière ce qu'on
verrait dans une forme conventionnelle
la truie pas rentrer sa vie la vie de
l'actrice passe dans un espace à peu
près grand comme ça c'est comme si on a
barré la truie ici et a passé sa vie
là-dedans
je vous dis littéralement elle se couche
elle se lève à l'heure des repas une
fois par jour lp le mange et elle se
recouche c'est
animal machine comme une machine qui
fait des canettes délicat robin la fin
du porcelet s'est pris dans un autre
aspect le plus petit possible pour être
le moins cher possible
nicolas devilder s'intéressent à ce
qu'on appelle le bien-être animal il n'y
a pas une entente sur qu'est-ce qu'elle
bien-être qu'est ce qui est le mieux
pour un animal dépendamment qu'on
regarde sa santé dépendamment qu'on
regarde son fonctionnement biologique
est ce qu il s est affectif positif
salaire comme du plaisir ou négatives
comme la peur de la soude la douleur du
stress de l'anxiété selon lui le port
mériteraient plus de respect c'est un
animal qui est doué de facultés
d'apprentissage ces importantes autant
qu'un chien par exemple un animal qui
démontre aussi des capacités cognitives
pour résoudre des problèmes pour
s'adapter c'est un animal qui est
curieux c'est un animal qui aime
explorer qui aime jouer
c'est un animal qui est social qui a
besoin d'être en groupe avec ses
congénères
pour les truites sont en cage
individuelle l ont pas beaucoup de
liberté d'expression de leur
comportement
ans
à l'origine l'implantation des cages de
gestation partait d'une bonne intention
au début des années 60 la plupart des
truies vivent en groupe dans des enclos
la compétition pour l'approvisionnement
en nourriture provoque des affrontements
et génère des blessures aux animaux
l'arrivée des cages individuelles est
une révolution plus de bagarres chaque
bruit reste toujours à la même place et
a accès à sa propre nation ce modèle là
de production intensive a mis des
décennies à se mettre en place a depuis
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale et
aujourd'hui on essaye de rechange et
réinventer peut-être le modèle vers
quelque chose qui va mieux concilier le
besoin des animaux c'est ce que les
éleveurs en régie biologique tente de
faire ils sont très peu nombreux un demi
pour cent du marché canadien
les exigences auxquelles ils doivent se
soumettre sont nettement plus élevés
qu'en élevage conventionnel
moi je crois que je vais manger une
viande qui vient d'un animal qui est
sain qu'ils étaient heureux si on veut
heureux
façon je pense qu'on peut le dire comme
ça pour un animal mais oui
chez du breton le principal producteur
de porc biologique en amérique du nord
les truies et leurs petits en trois fois
plus d espace conte élevage
conventionnel on est dans un enclos de
mirebeau on peut voir la truie qui est
libre de ses mouvements qui est capable
de se coucher deux fleuves et de se
retourner un peu comme elle veut
quand elle n'allait pas les truies sont
obligatoirement élevé en groupe ce que
vous voyez ici qui ressemblent à des
cages ce sont des enclos individuel ou
les truies vont manger ou se reposer à
leur guise
chaque turbine en incluant les l'espace
halle et en 32 pieds carrés chacune et
on voit le l'accès à l'extérieur il ya
un os 32 pieds carrés à l'extérieur
auxquelles elles ont accès
autre différence en régie biologique
les truies et les ports en engraissement
doivent avoir accès à de la paille
dans la nature les paris vont rapporter
beaucoup de leurs minéraux dans le sol
près continuent de fouiller de creuser
puis ce comportement là les occupe si on
pose pas faire là ils vont avoir
tendance à être agressif se ranger la
queue mutuellement de
ce phénomène qu'on appelle co dauphin j
est une forme de cannibalisme bien connu
en élevage conventionnel quand son dans
un parc qui est fait juste de plastique
de béton et de métal où il n'y a aucun
élément mobile qui a rien donc à se
mettre sous la dent bien ils finissent
par mettre la queue du voisin sous la
dent
les parents sont grignotées a que quand
une accumulation de stress ans qui
brisent amener l'eau quand il ya un
stress qui va arriver ils vont commencer
ce comportement là et le salé trop peu
quand ça va commencer bob c'est un peu
partout dans le parc ça va être un
comportement qui ça ils se reposent sûr
lié à la densité donc plus la densité
est importante plus à nîmes où
s'entassent et plus on a de risques plus
d'hygiène dans les parcs est mauvaise
plus on a dream
pour tenter de prévenir ce problème en
élevage conventionnelle on coupe la
queue des porcelets depuis longtemps une
manipulation est connu du grand public
savez vous pourquoi on coupe les belles
queue en tire-bouchon des cochons en
élevage industriel commercial aucune
idée parce qu'ils ont pas cette place
c'est parce que sinon je suis la bouffe
entre eux oh mon dieu mais c'est plus
rentable mais s'il tape aussi tracé
aussi il fallait pas
les porcs élevés en régie biologique
échappent à cette opération c'est
interdit de leur couper la queue sauf en
cas de problème particulier
mais comme rien n'est parfait les ports
biologique subissent tout de même la
plus douloureuse mutilation qu'on impose
à tous les pores la castration
ces images datent de plusieurs années
mais la méthode utilisée est encore là
même les porcelets de moins de 10 jours
sont castrés à vif avec un scalpel ou
des pinces
depuis 2016 l'utilisation d'un
analgésique et le commander la douleur
peuvent se faire sentir pendant
plusieurs heures voire plusieurs jours
par après et donc l'analgésie va à venir
comme quand on prend un tylenol ou quand
on prend quelque chose de gens là ça
vient calmer la douleur mais seulement
après le la castration et même si on
castres systématiquement les porcelets
c'est pour éviter que la viande issue de
ces animaux développent d odeur
désagréable lors de la cuisson le mieux
serait d'avoir une anesthésie plus une
analgésie l'anesthésié locale se fait
dans certains pays européens ont fait
des injections dans les testicules entra
testiculaire ça réduit un peu la douleur
mais cela supprime pas complètement et
puis les analgésiques eux peuvent aider
en postopératoire
malgré tout si on regarde l'ensemble des
conditions d'élevage des porcs dans
l'industrie nord américaine
cet expert est formel les conditions en
biologique les normes biologiques pour
les porcs sont clairement meilleurs que
le conventionnel en ce qui concerne le
bien-être
mais tout ça a un coût les consommateurs
pensez vous qu'ils sont prêts à payer
pour ça ce degré de bien-être animal
aucun coup oui un coup un coup majeur je
vous dirais le dogue despars et la
litière et atx et heureux
d'ailleurs quand vient le temps de
passer à la caisse les résolutions des
consommateurs s'envole souvent en fumée
si je vous disais que d'acheter du bacon
bio là où les parts sont mieux traités
ça beaucoup de presque deux fois plus
cher parce que vous en achèteriez
en quittant spécial
c'est parce qu'au bout de la ligne
c'est pas tellement spécial mais nous
avons levé tu es supporter paye ça se
ressent une fois de temps en temps aussi
comme je le fais déjà
les moyens de faire du bien-être animal
qui que ce soit j'ai envie de dire
abordable mais que que ce soit
accessible quand même
pour moi c'est ça quand je pense que il
ya un groupe de consommateurs qui qui
pensent comme moi
[Musique]
les cages de gestation pour les truies
ont été bannis en europe depuis
longtemps la suède en particulier a
interdit leur utilisation avant tout le
monde parce qu'elles les jugeaient trop
cruel et ce n'est qu'une des mesures
adoptées dans ce pays scandinave pour
améliorer le bien-être des ports
la suède est une référence en matière de
bien-être animal
nous sommes allés rencontrer les
éleveurs qui vivent au quotidien avec
des règles plus strictes qu'ailleurs
comme jeannette et länder qui élèvent
des porcs havas terrasse au centre du
pays
ici les cages de gestation sont
interdites depuis 35 ans
[Musique]
fourmies et facebook aussi j'aime voir
mitri en liberté je pense que c'est bon
pour leur santé c'est important pour moi
trois graines une spécialiste du
comportement porcin explique pourquoi
les cages de gestation ont été bénis
les cages sont contre nature pour les
truies et ne peuvent pas exprimer leur
comportement naturel si très restrictif
vous n'êtes jamais autorisé à mettre
détruit en cage sauf pour une brève
période de temps si elles sont
agressives envers les humains ou les
porcelets mais c'est très inhabituel au
niveau jour
chez janet et länder les truies sont
élevées en groupe pendant la brève
période où elles sont en cage avec leurs
porcelets elle doit pouvoir bouger et se
retourner sans difficulté elle dispose
de trois fois plus d espace que les
truies élevé dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne
tous ses porcs sont élevés sur la paille
alors que dans les autres pays de
l'union européenne ils sont élevées sur
du béton une étude a même été réalisée
pour déterminer la quantité requise de
litière pour les parts durant la période
d'engraissement
plastal nous donnons en moyenne 50 g de
paille par animal par jour ainsi moins
de 2% des parts suédois se mordent la
cure moins de 2% de kodu s'agit tout un
exploit quand on sait qu'il est interdit
de couper la queue des cochons dans tous
les types d'élevage qu'il soit
conventionnelles ou biologiques du
ménage comment faites-vous pour éviter
de leur couper la queue
makonda thoueilles que nous faisons
c'est que nous leur donnons plus
d'espacé ainsi que de la paille weegee
la mer tôt ce sont les deux choses qui
fonctionnent en suède
work in sweden
il faut dire qu'ici les porcelets sont
sevré à cinq semaines contrairement à
trois semaines ailleurs en europe et en
amérique du nord sevré plus tardivement
ils sont plus matures et ont moins
tendance à mordre la queue de leurs
congénères par la suite autre différence
il échappe à la castration à vif puisque
l'anesthésié locale est obligatoire en
plus de l'énergie si oui anastacia et
steak
avec l'anesthésiste ça prend plus de
temps
mais quand ça fait longtemps qu'on le
fait on s'habille dessus et c'est rapide
c'est la preuve que les éleveurs peuvent
castrés les porcelets correctement oui
on le groupe d'ex hampel date est formé
pour cette éleveuse la façon d'élever
les porcs au canada leur couper la queue
les mettre en cage omettre la nasse
saisis lors de la castration c'est
questionnable from its own strength pape
aino pour moi cette étrange je me
demande pourquoi vous faites it's you
work
si vous travaillez en fonction de
l'animal je crois que ça donnera un port
en meilleure santé
élevé dans ces conditions le port
suédois côte évidemment plus cher à
produire que celui de ses compétiteurs
européens
l'industrie porcine suédoise a
d'ailleurs failli s'effondrer en 1995
lors de l'entrée du pays dans l'union
européenne rappelle le vétérinaire qui
conseille janet et länder
nous pensions que nous pourrions vendre
notre rapport aux standards élevés de
bien-être animal dans toute l'europe
nous avons plutôt été envahies de porcs
à bas prix en provenance du marché
européen
nous avons perdu beaucoup d'éleveurs et
d'abattoirs entre 2012 et 2014
les éleveurs de porcs suédois ont réussi
à redresser la barre en 2014 en
multipliant les campagnes d'information
nous avons décidé de mettre de l'avant
nos standards plus élevés en matière de
bien-être animal et le fait que nos
animaux sont en très bonne santé
ont commencé à voir la différence et ont
accepté de payer plus cher pour de la
viande suédois
ça aider les éleveurs qui ont commencé à
être payés davantage par les abattoirs
notre autonomie alimentaire s'est accrue
le port consommer en suède parvenez à
60% de chez nous cette proportion est
maintenant de 85%
et fi ou en tout cas une simple si vous
voulez changer les choses les
consommateurs doivent être d'accord si
personne ne veut payer vous n'arriveriez
consulte nos by you can't wait
[Musique]
au canada les cages de gestation devait
être abandonnée en 2024 afin que les
truies soit élevé en groupe mais
certains membres de l'industrie ont eu
peur des coûts générés par la
construction de porcherie adapter à
cette nouvelle réalité
ils ont financé une étude réalisée dans
un centre d'expertisé forcé en
saskatchewan
le but évaluer la possibilité
d'améliorer le bien-être détruit en les
sortant de leur cage dix minutes par
semaine
cette scientifique a participé à
l'élaboration du protocole de recherche
nous sommes partis du principe que cela
devait être faisable embaucher un
employé à temps plein pour faire faire
de l'exercice autrui une fois par
semaine c'est gérable nous avons donc
proposé dix minutes d'exercice par
semaine par truie ce qui est peu j'en
conviens mais si ce n'est pas gérable
vous n'arriverez à rien il y aura des
ratés
au moment d'élaborer le protocole de
recherche la chercheuse qu'on voit ici
sur le terrain avec en tête le sort
réservé à l'industrie porcine au royaume
uni lorsque les cages de gestation ont
été abolis
je suis originaire du royaume uni où les
éleveurs sont passés à l'élevage de
truites en coupe dans les années 90 ils
ont dû investir pour y arriver mais
n'ont pas reçu de subvention
qu'est ce que la moitié d'entre eux ont
dû fermer leurs portes la viande de porc
étaient importés d'ailleurs où les ports
n'était pas élevé en groupe la même
chose pourrait se produire ici au canada
oui comme si
c'est l'industrie essuyé un revers
aurions-nous atteint notre objectif
mais finalement la solution de la sortie
hebdomadaire départ n'a pas été retenu
les dix minutes d'exercices n'ont pas
semblé diminué l'agitation détruit ni
améliorer leur confort parce qu'elles
restaient confinés dans leurs cages le
reste du temps il vaut mieux se diriger
vers l'élevage en groupe
au canada les cages de gestation devrait
finalement être interdite en 2029 la
nouvelle date butoir de l'industrie
46% des éleveurs canadiens ont pris de
l'avancé et élèvent déjà leurs fruits en
groupe
mais avec ce modèle les truies seront
tout de même gardé en cage près de la
moitié du temps soit 67 jours sur un
cycle reproducteur 245
mes qualifs un des plus importants
producteurs de porcs conventionnel au
canada a décidé de réduire encore plus
le temps passait en cage par ses truies
qu'est ce qui devrait être obligatoire
en 2029 pour y arriver la compagnie à
redessiner ses porcherie comme
l'expliqué la directrice des services
d'élevage
les enclos ouverts sont conçus pour
permettre aux truites d'entrée pour
manger à une extrémité et d'en ressortir
à l'autre réduisant ainsi les agressions
il ne s'agit pas simplement de mettre
les animaux dans un enclos ouvert il
faut les habituer au logement de groupe
car sinon ils peuvent se retrouver dans
des circonstances encore pire que ce
qu'ils étaient en cash ils peuvent
devenir agressif timide et craintif se
plaçant ainsi dans une situation
nuisible à leur santé martin deschamps
avec ce système les truies par seulement
30 jours en cage sur un cycle de
reproduction de 147 jours
leur permettre de marcher davantage
accroît leur longévité et améliorent
leur qualité de vie
quand on perd mais autrui d'exprimer
leur comportement naturel une foule de
comportements observés dans les
porcheries conventionnelle disparaissent
on ne voit plus de truies montre les
barreaux se cogner la tête ou mois
juillet dans le
ring
cette initiative ne concerne toutefois
qu'une des marques distribuées par la
multinationale mais la compagnie espère
que ses fournisseurs emboîteront le pas
tout au long de notre reportage nous
avons constaté que les consommateurs
sont de plus en plus sensibles aux
conditions de vie des animaux d'élevage
l'industrialisation fait qu'on optimise
les coûts donc on on les parque voilà
énormément donc c'est pas très sain
c'est pas très humain j'essaie vraiment
dans le vide mon régime le plus possible
la viande qui est mon éthique et
d'élevage
m'informer de connaître les compagnies
qui maltraitent les animaux et d'éviter
de manger cette viande puis après ce
geste aux consommateurs de choisir puis
c'est lorsque la demande qui vont faire
la différence à la fin
certaines compagnies les ont entendus
les gens se sont réveillés à ce qui se
passe dans l'agriculture dans les fermes
et de plus en plus avoir à avancer
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose
le qu'on puisse élever des animaux en
les respectant je pense que ce concert
on peut réellement changer les choses si
une entreprise de la taille de mespaul
leaf réussi à s'améliorer les autres
entreprises doivent réaliser qu'elles ne
peuvent aussi à l'avenir les
consommateurs demanderont davantage de
transparence de la part des compagnies
de transformation alimentaire qui élève
les animaux
on n'arrêtera pas ça va aller par en
avant on va toujours augmenter les
normes améliorer les normes bien-être
animal même non conventionnel on va le
faire on va le faire graduellement ça va
se faire au rythme que les gens vont
être capables de se le permettre c'est
une roue qui tourne et il travaillait en
grande ça
[Musique]